how you doing son  marina as commanding officer myself  i only lost one marine  his best friend waited there guarding  his body until it could be extracted you  ever hear that story before son  i always wanted to meet the man that  carried my son off that field  when i got out of the military all i  learned is fighting  but i want you to be different  vic what are you doing here man  paying some bills  i want to give y'all the better stuff  you mind rolling with him  that's travis prince man he just won  brazilian nationals what are you doing  here we gotta fight  there is always some theoretical fighter  who thinks he can take on the pros  i looked in his eyes oh he's got it  [Applause]  he got sucker punched by bling  everybody's gonna want to see a rematch  my flesh made a medal once you clap  hands and go  there's no hiding you about to dance  with the devil that mat is going to  expose every lie and confirm every truth  i needed  [Music]  it's all or nothing come on  [Music]  you